do you ever think that you'd be stuck
with me for the rest of your life
you do one movie with me and you're like
this guy is the one i'm gonna
the rest of i can't now we're stuck
together thank god
well first of all if we say bill and
sill
it's because bill is for brother-in-law
bill and still is for sister-in-law
s.i.l bill
and sil brother-in-law sister-in-law
forever you're you're myself
and you're the build to myself so i'm
married to drew's
uh producing partner nancy javonnen now
fallon
nancy javon and fallon i think um nan
for myself has always made me
see my own potential i want to
try everything i want to do it i know i
have this
passion and perseverance but it is not
coming from ego
or assumption i think i have to earn
everything
but when i met nan i felt like
things were possible dreams were real
and i wonder if she made you
feel that way too because after we did
fever pitch
you didn't want to act anymore
i don't think that was all by choice
you've seen my acting face to face
i think the world spoke we're good we're
good
anything else chibi what else you want
to do no i think that was you
after fever pitch i would just like i
think i grew up you know a little bit
and like i'm still growing up
and uh you know getting serious with
nancy so i didn't
i've never really gotten that seriously
like hey
time to focus up but she was clearly
magical and awesome and nancy is the
whole reason for for doing the
the show from our home because
we left 30 rock in our show
it was a thursday and i remember nbc
canceled the audience that day they said
no
definitely no audience because this
thing is is real
and nancy goes what are you going to do
and i go what i mean i don't know she's
like i mean you have to do
something so i go yeah i should do
something
so nancy held the sub she directed me
and i was just talking to the you know
an iphone but
i'm really lucked out i mean i got her
as a guest that's the hardest guess i've
ever had again
ever i asked her to do our show
and she wrote me an email and i said
this
know when i'm saying this i have
examined
everything i took every shelf off the
box that's like saying
no offense but i went to the top of the
mountain
i considered i dissected i
lived as if i was said yes i lived as if
i said no
i have worn this in every way possible i
could not have been more thoughtful
and i have to say not only is my answer
no
but please don't ever bring it up
[Laughter]
it's like she is so does not want to be
on camera at all
not even a remote bug of like hey this
is cool i'm like i'm going to be you
know
seriously so it was like when we had no
guests and anyone no one to talk to i go
honey maybe
maybe a little walk and talk and
everyone asks you some questions like
okay yeah all right good all right
let's just go to bed now i go it's five
o'clock let's take a couple
hours she's like freaking out every time
we would have an interview she would get
so
nervous and like and sweaty palms and
not know what [ __ ] but then when she
does it it's great and people loved it
you have
pioneered
three times now four times now
in the talk show space i think you
didn't like acting because it wasn't
enough
you couldn't do everything that you can
do
no i i i think that you know the movie
thing
is just i'm not billed for it you know
it's a lot of work
you know and i know that that's that's
helped me with my show
but i just think that you had too much
in you
and i'm curious if i have my facts
straight because
did lauren tell you and how long before
did he tell you that there might be
a chance of taking over for conan yeah
that was lauren
i was leaving snl i always wanted to
stay only three seasons on saturday live
because john belushi did
and i was like that's it three seasons
that's it so i went in the lord and i go
i think i have to leave sorry we had a
good thing and he's like
right you have a contract for six years
so you're not leaving anyway what else
is
on your mind you go well did your i was
gonna quit and everything he's like yeah
no
he goes i think he should do update you
know whatever and so we talked and
luckily
he's so right he's always right uh and i
i stayed
uh and did you know three more years but
then after six years i go
i think i should go just because i'm i'm
friends with everybody i'm friends with
the crew i'm friends with all the cast i
don't want to be one of those people
that
it gets it becomes a job then you get
crusty and you go
you're mad at something and you go i
just had the best experience
let's stop it now and wow i can't
believe i was this lucky
and he goes okay he goes you know uh
conan is leaving in like three years or
something that was oh six years
it was six years he said there was a
weird contract he signed with leno or
something
leno had six more years to the tonight
show and then conan was going to take
over something bizarre like that and i
go
oh yeah he goes i think he'd be good at
that and i go really and tina fey was in
the office too
and she goes i think so too she goes you
love people and you're still that person
i love people i love stories i love i'm
interested
i really am so i said great i'll see you
in six years you know
and then six years later you call me do
you think you ever forgot
that he said that to you was it always
on the back burner and could any job
match the potential of what that could
let you do
no that's a great question no way this
job let me do every single thing
i could ever think of ever ever and i
don't think anything was gonna work for
you until that happened
yeah interesting i never thought about
that
when you took over late night you knew
what to do
when it came to a home show you knew
what to do you knew when it was time
to dress a little differently and take
it into
the office so to speak of the studio but
it's hard when people
know things and they're capable and
they've got every detail and they're
managing it
i think sometimes that comes with a
rigidity
of like capability but there's some type
of like
almost stiffness yes
you're like a loose goose and yet you
know
exactly what to do when to do it no you
know what i
have good people around me that's it
that's the secret uh
you i've talked to you every step of the
way on all these things you're talking
about
lorne uh nancy you know and honest
honest people and good people surround
yourself with good people that's what
that's some you know every great person
that said that
you know so it's the truth and no matter
what age
whenever you figure it out you go oh and
i think a lot of people are figuring it
out now they go
oh i don't have to hang out with my my
my nephew larry
[Laughter]
i mean jesus corona is a real life
editor
i mean right because yeah we don't have
to do this anymore
this is not even rude if i leave here
because i don't want to be here you
you you have to do it is there a host
out there
that really speaks to you
johnny carson that would be my guy he
would do
interviews he would do song and dance i
mean
you know you got to meet him i mean it's
it's he's magic
he's like you can't really learn how to
do this without really doing it but
there's
dick cavett has a good book that you
should read that's good i know you
love him and i loved
when you did a show in like ode to dick
cavett
remember that we had the whole set from
the from the show from the 70s i mean
nobody broke
format the way you did you had the
rolling stones on
and played their documentary you changed
everything you changed what was possible
and what people thought they could do
research process anything like
particular that's
very important to you uh i have
really good segment producers so the
segment producer talks to the guests
like
before they come on do the interview so
they kind of like try to get you like
any good story like how was your flight
and uh
after doing this for 10 plus years now i
know everybody
really pretty well and i've seen them at
their highs and the lows
so i also have personal stories where
i'll talk to people now
and now i go like hey are you still
collecting uh you know troll dolls or
something
you're like no i'm out of you know and
then it sparks a
thing then it's a snowball then it
becomes a giant you know and it's
great i love when that happens you make
it personal yeah
so you know the pace of snl you know the
pace of movies and you know the pace of
talk shows
what am i in for am i fooling myself i
keep saying
i've been working since i was 11 months
old from 4 a.m to 11 p.m every day five
days a week
night shoots on weekends like i've got
this i've seen you
am i wrong am i really wrong i'm afraid
i'm really wrong
no i i think for the first time i got
cocky
and it's gonna bite me in the ass so
badly bill i couldn't think of a better
person for this sill than you and
honestly you always go
not only just like you never take the
easy way out
you go if i'm gonna get from here to
there i'm gonna work my way from here to
there and i
know from being your family and your
friend that how hard you work to get to
this stage i mean it's non-stop there's
no one with a better
work ethic than you and you crush it and
you always do no matter what it is
and so yeah this is a giant thing it's a
life change
but it's a good thing the thing that i
said
that i believed made me maybe
potentially correct for this job was
that when i was seven
i was in tokyo uh et world press tour
and this woman uh shoved a
autograph under the bathroom stall and
was holding the paper out and i was like
oh life is
about to really change from here on out
like there's the moment where you know
things are going to be different and
that somehow made me aware that
how i spoke to people like
was all exchanges and that
all those exchanges if they could be
filled with dignity
and connectivity then that was
what was required and that's what felt
right and that became my own personal
standard
everyone's got a great drew story no
one's got a bad drew story everyone's
like oh
i met you at the thing and you're so
nice to me and nice to my kids i mean
i've been around you and that happens
but you're the same
person you care about everyone you're
interested in everyone i read this thing
in a book it said listen to people for
they have their stories too
i was 14 and it was like all these
little
breadcrumbs have led me to be someone
who absolutely does love to engage does
believe in
the respect of people does believe an
exchange has an opportunity
to have positive energy yeah and we're
probably having the same problems as you
are
no matter how awesome their life looks
there's something where it's not no one
has a perfect life
someone's like yeah i'm going through
the same thing and you go what i thought
you were just all
everyone's got a story and everyone can
relate we're all
you know i was talking to someone the
other day and said there's water in all
of us
and there's water in the earth and it
was like like 90 percent were water
it just got so deep i was like okay uh
yeah this is the best part i've ever
been to yeah but i was like
it was a zoom part you pioneered when
you came on late night there was no
social media
in tv there was
no um viral clips
that everybody aspires to now you
had games people were not doing that
you brought song and dance and variety
and
most hosts cannot bring that they just
don't have
that skill set they have different ones
and everybody has theirs but you
were like a triple threat with that and
you just seem to
put it all together in this very large
mosaic and tapestry
but that we wrap ourselves up in and i
just
know that you've made the world a more
innovative safer and better place
and i love you and i love everything
you've done
and i love everything you've put out
there and that doesn't even go into the
snl
category which is oh my god
i just what i know that's so nice but
like
wouldn't wouldn't it be funny if oprah
was sitting behind me
i was like okay now this makes it
okay i'm sorry i thought i'm still sorry
i think one of the hardest i've ever
cried in my life
was at your wedding like i was
having a major problem because i was
convulsing so hard i was worried i was
ruining it
i would have no but i was i was staring
you know i was staring at you
so at our wedding we had a tiny wedding
but we had a videographer at our wedding
and
so they knew that our wedding song was
rainbow connection
they thought it'd be funny to surprise
us you don't surprise anyone
on their wedding just what don't i don't
even like surprises in general
definitely not surprising when on their
wedding
uh and so i'm coming down the aisle
first i guess just to you get ready and
then nancy's gonna
be walked down by her dad and i go there
and i get to the front and there's a
kermit the frog doll
in the front row yeah like flopped
flopped in there like there's a puppet
with no hand
nancy's coming in and i'm welling up
like she looks beautiful
and then the corner of my eye there's a
kermit the frog dog
just zapping all the romance zapping all
the romance out of the wedding i'm like
it's so bold and i go what the what is
going on
it's like sticking you might as well
stick it to the back of nancy's dress
that's just going down the aisle this is
the kermit the frog like strapped
to the back with suction cups like the
garfield in the
in the minivan and then we got the video
there's 30 shots of kermit the frog
easter eggs hidden in our do you have a
dream guest
that still hasn't done the show there's
many things i wish i asked prince to do
a sketch
because he was funny and he liked me and
we always get along
and i know he would have done one you
know but he just at the time you go like
he's prince and i don't want to mess
with him and
but he was always funny he liked me and
so he would make jokes and like in his
prince way and
he had a great sense of humor he
borrowed kirk's guitar once from the
roots and
kirk was honored and he's playing his
guitar and he's just awesome you know
his prince
and when he's done because his guitar
tech was late or something
isn't that hilarious a guitar tech for
prince and you're late
oh god anyways at the end he finishes
the thing
takes the guitar off throws it there's
no one there to catch it because the
guitar check is late
guitar breaks kirk's like what the
you know and prince just acting cool you
know he just walks off
and then they're like dude you just
broke like kirk's guitar and
kirk's like a that was my guitar b i
wanted to have that guitar after you
played it
the whole point of it yeah now now it's
a coaster it's he holds his
uh his beer cans uh so no prince felt so
bad
and got it fixed and repaired and you
know he was like oh my gosh you're
kidding me
he assumes that's his life you take the
throw the guitar right someone someone's
there to catch it
no no and so but he was funny and so
it's those things you look back and
you're like ah you missed that one you
know
but you know probably the real answer
would be probably nancy's mom
i'd like to see i'd like to have her
look at me and talk to me and say like
hey
that's who your daughter married she's
good
to edit this out or add more tears
one or the other uh but yeah i'd say
probably um just to let her know
who i am and who her daughter fell in
love with and that she has grandkids and
does so many things you know i hope it's
okay to say this but i'm
convinced that pam couldn't be happier
do this are you gonna do this to people
i
this is what your thing is i uh what's
gonna happen do you come on
dude where's the kermit the pride i need
something
i in case it gets need heavy
i need to have the doll with the no hand
i need to have the puppet somewhere
okay can i quickly take oh my god
my mother made a scrapbook oh my god
no there's much word that's me is jean
challenge for halloween i
loved gene challenge every kid was
dressed as gene shallow for halloween
could you you had you couldn't turn the
corner without some kid dressing as
the movie critic gene shallot oh my god
oh was that on snl that's
snl i'll tell you why it's cool this is
the last year edie baskin who's a
legendary photographer for snl
yep retired after my season but you
could tell it's an idi basking photo
because look into my eyeballs
see that woman and standing in front of
the light that's yes
that's edie so from my photo to gilda's
photo
to garrett morris to eddie murphy to
name it 80 baskins behind in their eyes
i was lucky enough to i believe get an
idi baskin photo
from the 1982. she's the coolest still
the youngest
that's right now who's that latin
superstar because
i love his work live in the video
what is he what's so bad i love it oh
but going back to like the 50s
gel was on sale and
they said a little deaf will do you but
i did a lot of depth your dad still
looks exactly the same
like that could be jim last month
it does look exactly the same doesn't he
like exactly
yeah he doesn't do nothing yet nothing
different he looks exactly the same
and he loves you and so proud of you i
love him so much too
and i just love getting to like hang out
and talk to him because i know
song is gonna break out he's got us
harmonized with everything i mean the
guy harmonizes with a doorbell
[Laughter]
i love it
she's like i'm going to do the pots and
this is the time where
you only had 10 pictures on your phone
so someone thought that was important
i love it piazza mia wait this is my
modeling career this is me i'm that's a
calvin klein model seriously
that's not the reaction god i'm the most
the reaction is yes
i bought what did i mean by i was really
again not the reaction yes i
was a supermodel what is the problem
oh yeah let's see the calvin klein ad
oh we'll see the calvin kleinhound oh
i'm embarrassed now i totally remember
that do you remember this dude
absolutely
it was the weirdest little picture i
couldn't see it that i remember
this guy shows up at the party's like no
problem i'm just looking at the
beautiful
sunset no explosion
finish this sentence okay there have
been
six hosts of the tonight show i want to
be remembered as the one who
did the most with it there he is
i think they'd all be psyched that we
have the
internet and all this stuff now that
steve allen would be like
you did what with the taj you got to be
kidding me there's people in
you know dubai watching me
this is like it's bigger than what
anyone thought this would be it's a tiny
little show
you know uh and and now it's global
it's i think everyone if they were alive
uh and everyone who is alive they go
this is great you're doing
the most of what you can make of the
show you're doing it
thank you drew we need you
everyone needs you they need the show uh
this all makes sense and uh everyone's
so lucky they get to see this
you're awesome and we need this we need
something we need something
we need you we need drew
you